the Joe Rogan experience so your mom
would happen so she gets only decaf
espresso because she loves the taste of
coffee but she can't have caffeine
she likes espresso though yeah hmm I
guess it tastes the same it's like
there's a bunch of different kinds of
espresso right these different beans and
[ __ ] like some people make it like super
bitter those the people that love doing
that cranking machine to pop it in there
and crank it tap it down I like those
Nespresso capsules pop those [ __ ] and
enough to think too much
meanwhile this Turtles out there choking
the desk probably right it's aluminum no
it's not not plastic but still [ __ ]
Turtles man lose the last time you saw a
turtle ID I saw a turtle in Hawaii okay
so once but you see straws every day
they're courtesy he strolls more yeah
[Laughter]
the problem really is waste management
that's the problem how the [ __ ] does the
waste get in the ocean in the first
place you tell me it's inevitable that
everyone's so gross that all the garbage
has to get in the ocean no matter what I
don't think that's true I think we need
to do a way better job of collecting
garbage and treating garbage and
treating our own garbage I just come up
with a more comprehensive plan to avoid
all this [ __ ] getting into the ocean
this is not enough funding in order
manned grete Thornburg is only 16 she
can only do so much
I used to feed it to pigs before they
figured out landfills oh really
did they yeah it's all everything they'd
everything as much as they could I think
Wow the restaurant should be fine they
should I got a pig that's sick families
made I think it was Ari it was either
Ari or Kalin might have been Kalin that
told me they were in China and there was
a restaurant that had toilet and the
toilet was a hole Ari it was it all
right yeah but in nono but in the hole
at the bottom was pigs he was [ __ ]
into a pig sty
and the pigs would eat your [ __ ] and
that this is common cool I'm pretty sure
it was Kalin what in the [ __ ] already
definitely told me he had a [ __ ]
whole yeah yeah they also got chased out
of a Chinese girl's house by a man with
a baseball bat right and something about
street oil or something like that like
the the food was cooked using like the
oil from the does it different that's a
different story
there's a story that I almost forgot
about you just said that that's the
story of them that's what already
brought yes yes sewer water water they
were making cooking oil at a sewer water
there's literally people going into the
sewer and turning that [ __ ] water in the
cooking oil I know you're saying there's
no way it makes sense
it was the Asians doing that no my
girlfriend is Asian and she's like the
grossest [ __ ] ever like blood soup view
from the inside of a pig toilet so there
it is it's kind of cool
look at that I don't need that pig
things he's a minority village somewhere
in Yunnan Province China the pig follow
me to the toilet position itself under
it waiting I was very confused when I
started using toilet paper for reasons
oh my god cuz it was licking his [ __ ]
I just cool it and like pig toilets just
start coming up I tried to [ __ ] right on
the pig spit that is so gross but now go
see if you find cooking oil made from
sewage dun dun I know a lot of people
like wait what no I think it was Vice I
think vice had a video on it and it was
all about how there is a market for
people making cooking oil and he's
really poor towns they literally climb
into the sewers and they take out human
[ __ ] and turn into cooking oil got a
royal they call it gutter oil header
disgusting recycled oil and sewage
illicit cooking oil which has been
recycled from waste oil collected from
sources such as restaurant fires grease
traps slaughterhouse waste and sewage
from sewer drains look at that one on
the far right says Chinese guttural you
click on that disgusting this is the
video that I've seen before recycled oil
and Su
used to cook Chinese Street food Jesus
Christ bro they get into the potty and
then they they filter all the poop out
and they get the oil
these filters get the oil out of the
poop and then they cook your noodles in
that whoa
that's why we need regulation would you
taste it that's right no that's why we
need America Young Turks it was them
they'd get one too oh yeah definitely
yeah this guy opens up or his woman
rather opens up Oh
she scooped it out literally I was wrong
[Laughter]
[Applause]